this whole culture that tells young  people that their entire like middle to  high school career is all about getting  into the university it's not about what  are you interested in it's what is going  to look good on your application it's  like i need to show that i did like 50  hours at a freaking animal shelter to  prove that i'm a good person so that  harvard will let me in it's all so  manufactured and it strips young people  from being able to actually be  innovative and be creative and find  their passions and actually work that's  why gen z is the least experienced  generation going into the workforce  because we were all so damn focused on  getting into ivy leagues if you're  already working if you already know what  you're interested in yeah why waste all  of that time especially if it's  something that you could just go do now  if you could go to a community college  knock out a few of those credits and  then go get a job